Kirk Herbstreit set to join us on loan
from Allstate and Herbie joins us now I
was talking about this a little while
ago on the show you know Michigan not
preparing or being prepared to face army
and nearly losing in overtime could you
imagine if Michigan and lost that game
Herbie oh my gosh in a year where Jim
Harbaugh is in his fifth year he's 8 and
11 against ranked teams coming in some
of his own fans are saying this isn't
working
when can we beat Ohio State when can we
beat Michigan State what's going on why
can't we win these big games and to NSA
we're to lose the army before they get
to a bye week and then they got to go to
Madison to take on the Badgers nice it's
better off we don't think about that I
think we just we just say they found a
way to win and move forward but they've
got a lot of work to do if they want to
accomplish what their fan base expects
from them in 2019
what advice is a former quarterback
would you give Trevor Lawrence this year
well far be it for me to give him any
advice did the Freak I would tell him
it's just from following this sport and
being in the perch that I've been in for
24 years and watching guys come and go
I would probably advise him and say just
be careful of listening and it's hard
not to today but feeling these almost
unrealistic expectations what happens
what I've watched guys feel as if they
told me after the season they
subconsciously feel that they have to
live up to that hype and and there's a
tendency to want to make the 50-yard
touchdown on every play and so it's not
fun to gain 3 yards 3 yards 4 yards
seven yards and slowly let the game come
to you it's easier to want to hit Justin
Ross for a 60 yard touchdown or or T
Higgins for a big throw and and I think
there's just a tendency to force the
issue and you know in this sport
when you
trying to make plays instead of letting
those plays come to you there's a bit of
a problem and I think Clemson has an
offense that's probably the biggest
thing that they have to fight against is
trying to live up to such big big
expectations when you have a quarterback
like that but he's as good as they say I
mean he's he's the best I've seen I mean
Andrew Luck was a really good when we
started thinking about who will rule
transition to the NFL luck was one
coming out of college that you just
could not wait to see what he would do
you know the one that comes to mind
before that would be Peyton Manning when
you just look at him you think okay this
guy's going to the NFL you can have a
great career Trevor Lawrence has
everything you're looking for which is
his size his approach to the game his
humility his willingness to work his
willingness to want to get better
it's going to be scary where he'll be a
year from now and once he gets done with
his junior year and and whoever is lucky
enough to be sitting there at number one
will obviously have a quarterback that
they can put the franchise on his back
what was the biggest surprise this
weekend to you besides our me the two
probably that stood out to me was
Nebraska with Scott frost up 17 and
Boulder and Colorado fighting all the
way back to beat them was probably one
that stands out and then this is this is
one that you have to be you know a just
a degenerate like me to have stayed up
for that it's a lay out in Seattle with
Cal and Washington and by the time I got
home it was almost 3:00 in the morning
and that game delayed so late it was
still on and Cal ended up knocking off
Washington late and that one even though
he thought it might be competitive I
don't know if anybody thought Cal would
go to Seattle and knock off the Huskies
so that not one was a Late Late Late one
but a big surprise yeah I thought the
USC went over Stanford surprised a lot
of people including most people at USC
yeah yeah that's another fan base it's
got mixed emotion
damn because of course they're fighting
for the Trojans and hoping the Trojans
win but some of them are openly cheering
for clay Helton to lose because they
want they want quote unquote Urban Meyer
or Bob Stoops and so you know I you know
how fickle fans can be but yeah SC how
about that that's a true freshman
cadence Lovis who stepped in there and
had a monster game against Stanford and
you know FC is another team that you
talked about a head coach that's facing
a lot of threats and pressure and think
about that opening up their season with
Fresno Stanford at BYU Utah at
Washington at Notre Dame in a year where
if you don't win ten new and potentially
win the pac-12 you're fired and you lose
your starting quarterback week one
that's not that's a lot of pressure but
they look good last week when's the last
time you looked at a sign doing College
GameDay and it just made you laugh out
loud and I there are so many of them out
there that you know you almost get
immune to them so I typically depending
on where we go try not to look at them
and see what they might have but yeah I
mean we we actually have a segment where
we have the signs we show different
signs that that are out there but I
can't think of I can't think of a one or
a category they had a lot of fun last
week with ed order on different signs
and pictures of him and of course he's
become one of the great characters in
the sport with his voice and the way he
talks people like to have fun with him
but the way he got LSU all of a sudden
figuring out how to score touchdowns and
not just play defense you want to talk
about a team after two weeks that it's
kind of trending in the right direction
yeah there's a quarterback Joe burrow
and an offense Joe Brady came over from
the Saints where he's 29 years old and
he's become like the the genius of the
sport after two weeks he implemented the
Saints offense and at LSU and this kid
Joe burrow is the
ciara it looks like running a lot of
same plays that drew brees runs and
Texas could not figure out how to stop
them so that that's a team that to keep
an eye on and what a matchup that
potentially could be with Joe burrow in
this new offense going up against two in
Tuscaloosa in Tuscaloosa Layton here I
mentioned at the outset of the interview
you're joining us on behalf of Allstate
the Allstate mayhem moment predictions
how are you doing with that this year um
pretty challenging when you look at
entire slate of games and try to figure
out where the the mayhem moment might be
and of course that could be an upset
that could be a close call like we had
last week with with army and Michigan so
I two days I I have a prediction I might
start asking Fritzi who he likes no no
no I'll bet against that if you're
asking Tracy for advice yeah Tuesday we
predict on Twitter where where the
mayhem moment might be and then Saturday
night with Fowler and I on ABC we kind
of react to today and and find our
mayhem moment of the day which is much
easier than trying to predict it on
Tuesday her be great to talk to you safe
travels as always thanks for joining us
absolutely great catching up here today
and talk to you soon for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app